still scattered on the floor the
suspect's cap bag and jacket he'd just
been pulled out of this van at gunpoint
there were bullet holes in the
windscreen of the vehicle but the
suspect was dragged out alive I heard
the police straight away and as soon as
I heard it I came to the window and then
I then saw everything like I saw them
like draw their guns or whatever they
had at him I saw them drag him out he
seemed to be complying with them no they
drugged him out he wasn't really
complaining stopping him was the
priority after three people had been
killed and three others were in hospital
that moment brought this violent spree
across this city to an end the 31 year
old was taken into custody arrested on
suspicion of murder nineteen-year-old
Barnaby Weber from Somerset was one of
those stabbed to death on ilkeston road
at 4am where a night out partying had
been drawing to an end
he was a keen cricketer his Club
Bishop's hole near Taunton said he was a
key part of their success playing over
30 games and scoring 622 runs
friends in Nottingham placed a cricket
shirt and cap among the flowers in Saint
Peter's Church
there were tributes to to another 19
year old called Grace who'd been on a
night out with Mr Weber
after the stabbings the suspect drove
the white van into the city center past
the theater Royal where he hit three
pedestrians one is critically injured in
hospital
the third victim a man in his 50s was
found dead here on magdala Road
as forensic searches got underway armed
police were back on ilkeston road
smashing their way into this terraced
house as their investigation moved at
PACE we are still in the early stages of
the investigation and need to determine
exactly what the motives were behind
this attack we are keeping an open mind
and are working closely with
counter-terrorism policing to establish
the facts
it could take days to establish the
motive the forensic searches finding
every witness or piece of CCTV
several properties remain cordoned off
and for now it is a murder inquiry led
by Nottingham Mission Police
this city stands together and waits for
an explanation
Tom Parmenter Sky News Nottingham